Grahame you you put this screenplay
together almost as if it were a puzzle
itself I'm curious as you're starting to
write it was that part of your thinking
yeah that was very much the thinking
there was sort of this idea that you
know Alan Turing was obsessed with
puzzles codes games they were so
fundamental to his life and so the whole
movie would be a puzzle a code a game so
we would take these three time periods
of his life the fifties with his arrest
and persecution the 40s with his wartime
work at Bletchley Park and in the 1920s
with his sort of first falling in love
first being exposed to cryptography and
the sort of intertwining of those two
events in his heart and in his mind and
sort of take these three time periods
and chop them up out of order present
them to you the audience as a puzzle as
a code and so you are trying to solve
the puzzle of Alan the same way Alan
would be trying to solve a puzzle so I
had met Graham actually on a staffing
meeting when I was working in television
as an assistant and we just stayed in
touch and I was having a party at my
house and invited Graham who at the time
was I think working with my roommate and
I was sort of doing the song and dance
you know you do when you you're not
working and letting people not feel
sorry for you and I said I had option
this book and he actually overheard and
interrupted the conversation and said
you know I've been obsessed with Alan
Turing my whole life and you know one
day that's gonna be my passion project
and fortunately there was no one else
knocking so we still made him pitch us
there was a time where we sort of took
it to the studio system and it never
really felt like an organic fit at a
studio
it definitely wasn't in there you know
sort of rubric of the types of things
they were making so after they sat on it
for about a year we thankfully got it
back it reverted back to us and during
that time Graham's script topped the
blacklist so there was more and more
attention on it so things like let's
being the top unproduced screenplays in
Hollywood right so when we got it back
thankfully there were a lot of people
who are interested and potentially
coming on board and helping us to
finance it but our issue was primarily
finding a partner who had the same
creative vision for the project and who
was really passionate and intent on
bringing it to the screen and that's
when we cross paths with teddy
thank you that's well I thought this is
working just right down right we can go
I'll never ever get some actors very
soon you know and and from my standpoint
you know it was very lucky for the three
of us and Graham to come together with
the shared vision for the type of film
that we hope to make and to try and
protect the legacy of Alan Turing while
at the same time trying to make
something interesting cinematic that has
a number of different genres intertwined
and I think that we started out looking
as an American writer and three American
producers looking for a British director
because that just sort of seemed to make
sense and it just happened that we met
this crazy Scandinavian Viking in Morton
Tilden I always loved history I thought
I knew history really well and I was
shocked how much of it I didn't know and
it I I was it saddened me in many ways
also because I it felt it felt that this
man should be you know he should be in
the front cover of my history book when
I was at school and why didn't I know
more about him and I became obsessed and
also I wasn't outside at how would that
time I mean this to me is a movie about
sorry it's a movie about you know it's
to me it became the heart of it it's
sort of like a celebration of being
different and how you know this man
could do these amazing things because he
wasn't burdened down by normality you
know his thoughts could soar free and
it's and it became you know a very
important movie and of course it's it's
it's you know you throw yourself up in a
deep end even if you want to do you know
anguish film and it's it's it and it's a
character-driven dialogue-driven british
period movie you know there's nothing
you can hide behind it's no explosions
there's no nothing you know you have to
you have to get this right and and but I
didn't have to say any of the dialogue
so and actually actually I've acted out
me and Graham we spent six to eight
months together polishing the script and
we acted out this script many times just
the two of us it was really I would
always play Kira's part and Morton with
you I don't know why but I was always
Joe always Joan yeah we're so glad that
there is no video or morning
that by the way it's the worst thing
you've ever seen I'm so glad Kira that
you didn't have to see any of that that
would be Karen Benedict was this story
at all familiar to you or is it not
well-known even in the UK I I'd first
read about it I think in about 2009
where there was a big push in the media
in England to try and get a pardon for
him and I actually I remember reading it
in The Guardian newspaper and being
totally shocked that I didn't know I
mean and as somebody who does love
history and particularly that period and
of course I'd read sort of about
Bletchley Park but didn't specifically
know about Alan Turing and what he
didn't what had been done to him I was
really shocked and actually had a
conversation I was meeting my agent that
day and remember having we had lunch and
talking about him because she'd known a
little bit more because of breaking the
code which had been a theater play and
then on television and and then a couple
of years later said you remember that
Alan Turing conversation well they're
making a film and they've offered you a
part so do you want to do it and
actually even before reading the script
when yes I want to be a part of this
good thing you wrote a good script I'd
seen breaking the code on television a
long time ago now but Derek Jacobi he's
extraordinary is Alan Turing and they
made a real impact on me then although I
stayed away from it obviously before you
know creating our version of Alan I one
of the reasons I wanted to do it was how
shocked I was at how little I knew
though even despite the play or the
vague memory of the play many dominated
like I said by the extraordinary
performances of Derek Jacobi I I thought
this is sort of it's it's it's the
sickening irony at the end of a film
where you see a man who is utterly
betrayed by the democracy and country
and culture that he hopes saved from
fascism being punished in the way he's
punished for his sexuality that is
completely for me amplified by thinking
why the hell do we all not know about
this man why is he not on banknotes with
Newton and Darwin why is he not on
history books like more certain social
books and it's he he has a heroic status
and yet through amalgamation of certain
circumstances he's been overlooked I
think partly because of the Official
Secrets Act partly because of his demise
and the shameful stain on our culture
that that is and and also partly because
he wasn't interested in from
himself he could have had that paper
that could have could have won him the
prize if he'd written about algorithms
in the early part of his career and I
think he he pursued artificial
intelligence a little bit more in terms
of self publicizing later in his life
and his career but he never had that one
moment that could have you know marked
him in you know the scientific firmament
but I yeah it was it was very much one
of the reasons I wanted to try and do
some justice to him and spread his
legacy and his story to it to a broader
audience it was one of the attractions
to this really incredible script that I
read and I was here doing Star Trek I
was Bank on for JJ and in one of the off
days from being a psychopathic super
engineered space thing I I read this
script and and could sort of you know
hear Elgar and being transported back to
the homeland and but in all seriousness
just the way he unraveled with the
mystery of enigma was it was just it was
so beautiful you mean and the way you
meet him he's so unapologetic it's funny
but he's he's he's very determined and
particular and awkward and mmm a
character that's not afraid of not being
liked which is a sort of joy you know
you don't feel they're being patronized
by a meeting this nice chap who is very
brilliant how much reference is there
about the way he spoke what he looked
like the way he walked or you have to
kind of create nothing cloth nothing
no yeah there's no footage that's not--
there's no audio or film footage of and
there are photographs of him stills of
him proposing posing there are sort of
him running but that but as far as his
speech pattern goes that the very
particular stammer he had his
physicality the way held himself his way
of making eye contact or choosing not to
in averting his gaze of the way he held
this pen and his appearance his his
motion through landscapes and his of his
interaction with people that was all
it's anecdotally very very richly
described in some fantastic biographies
and I was fortunate enough to meet a
couple of people who knew him but there
was no firsthand sort of source material
to base my interpretation on it was was
by you know description I think it made
complete sense to both of us that it was
a
great friendship and a meeting of minds
and I think from my point of view it
made complete sense that she choose
partnership over necessarily a romantic
sort of love and particularly given that
that era you know if if she'd gone with
somebody who perhaps she would have had
a great sexual relationship with and all
the rest she would have been pretty much
tied to a kitchen sink you know and with
this person her brain was allowed to be
engaged in what what she was totally
passionate about so I thought that made
complete sense and you know that
conversation happened where he said I
can't go through this I'm I'm a sexual
man this isn't right for you or for me
and she did define their relationship in
the times of curious just echoed and say
look this is this is better than most
people have this is an extraordinary
thing and it's it's more than enough for
me and we can make this work and there
was he just he felt he couldn't he felt
he would be living too much of a lie to
his true nature but you're right it is a
story about love rather than sexuality
it's a story about a man who's not
allowed to love because his love is a
banned and punishable love it's even
saying those words just seems so alien
to me but sadly we still live in a time
where it seems however nationalism rears
its head you you you the same prejudices
the same scapegoats are made out of
minorities and gay men at the forefront
of that abuse whether it's in Russia or
Middle East or Turkey or Greece with the
Golden Dawn and it hasn't gone away it's
not a history lesson sadly but going
back to the film yeah it's it's very
much about that very much about a man
who wasn't allowed to love I mean you
imagine that here's this guy 27 years
old comes right out of university and
now he's sort of sort of recruited by
mi6 keeping these incredibly difficult
top-level state secrets for the secret
intelligence services
you know he's sort of finding himself in
the middle of like a real world thriller
with the fate of the free world on the
shoulders of this 27 year old
mathematician it's remarkable so they
sort of tension of that and the pressure
of that and the mystery of that is
something we always used to important to
us to convey and so yeah what we wanted
to do was sort of explain explain how he
broke the code in sort of a big
conceptual way
so but what you saw on the film is true
I mean that that's how they did it it's
the technical term is crib based
cryptography for those of you who really
yeah but it's you know this idea that
yeah this idea that you could break the
code by using words that you already
knew we're gonna be in the message so
so-called cribs no one in the history of
cryptography had ever done that before
Alan Turing it was the sort of hinge
moment in the in the history of
cryptography and so the silly starting
messages the CIA oh why whether Heil
Hitler
this really was how they broke the code
and so we sort of tried to show you and
really convey to the audience a big
picture in a big picture way like how
ingenious this was and how ingenious it
was to sort of figure that out you have
obligation to really tell the story
through fully and and and what what
really happened at the same time you
have to make it engaging because you
know he's his life to serve that you you
you have to tell a movie and we didn't
want it to be so like a dusty history
lesson we wanted to be a fun thrilling
and engaging film because that's what
he's like I see the Serbs Kyra I'm gonna
have the last question for you and I
want to give you two a couple of
footnotes one is Alan Turing was in a
movie not that long ago where he was a
straight man in a love triangle and
secondly at the NSA in the United States
right now the Society of LGBT agents is
called the Alan Turing Society this is
obviously a period film but I'm curious
what you think it's modern relevance it
is and what you hope people take away
from the imitation game well I can to
talk about Jane's character from that
what I thought was fascinating which is
obviously shown in the film is the idea
of a woman who is in a man's world and
can't can't find her place in it wasn't
allowed into the room hasn't allowed her
place at the table which is true to what
happened what we didn't cover in the
film but is true to Joan's story is the
fact that once she did get into the room
and she was doing exactly the same job
as men she was paid a fraction of what
all of the men were paid I don't know
yeah well and that's that's sort of what
I thought was interesting you know
because you look at the feminist
argument today and what are we fighting
for it's a place at the table in equal
pay and what was she fighting for in
1943 it was a place at the
and equal pay so you know and I think as
Benedict said before as well you
prejudice hasn't gone away you know and
this is a film that is trying to
celebrate differences because we have to
because continually we don't and people
get destroyed because of it so I I mean
I don't think that you can have a more
relevant story really